I want to go to now
longtime Putin critic and nemesis
Bill Browder.
He was actually once
the largest foreign investor in Russia.
Now, of course, a wanted man by Putin
And, Bill,
I always appreciate speaking to you.
And I want to start with something
that I know you understand
better than almost anyone.
That St Petersburg official
that I spoke with earlier
today is now in exile in Georgia,
but he's speaking out, signed a letter
asking Putin to free Alexei
Navalny, demanding Russians
have the rights that they deserve.
And he told me some
who signed that letter
are still in Russia.
How fearful are you for
all of these people's safety?
Very fearful.
And basically there is no
willingness on the Putin regime
to tolerate any dissent.
Anybody who says anything like that
will be put on a list
and those people will become targets.
And so I would imagine
that if anyone who signed
that letter is still in Russia,
then they'll be a target to either
be arrested or perhaps worse
And you also heard Dimitri say
that he and others
who signed the letter who
who are not in Russia and of course,
many of them like here in countries
that are very friendly to Russia
they're looking forward to returning,
but they need
Putin's regime to fall first.
That's how he put it.
And then he told me something else
about Alexei Navalny.
I want to play that for you, Bill.
Navalny is
slowly dying in prison right now,
but I hope that he's strong enough
to survive
until something changes in Russia.
And basically, I think he's in prison
until Putin is in power.
From what you see, Bill, do you see a day
anytime soon
in the context of this war
and all the failures
where Putin's regime actually falls?
Navalny is free.
Dmitri and others can return.
Is that day near?
Well, it's a possibility.
But I would
I hate to say
it's it's a low possibility.
You know, for example, if if Ukraine
could push Russia out of Crimea,
Crimea was such an important thing
for Putin.
That might be the kind of thing
that would lead
to the Putin regime
fracturing and falling.
But you also have to understand that
that if
if for some reason that were to happen,
Putin would probably lose his life.
And Putin is such a little man right now,
so scared for his own life
that he's ready to sacrifice
the lives of
hundreds of thousands, perhaps
even millions of men
to keep this war going, to
keep himself from being defeated.
And so
we have
that's why I say
it's a low probability event
that the regime falls
because Putin will hang on for dear life
and he'll put so much at stake
in the meantime.
And of course, assassinations
inside Russia, outside Russia,
using poison is sort of a signature
calling card for Putin's forces.
Navalny, not the only Putin enemy
who has been poisoned.
And I actually spoke recently
to the lawyer
and also to the son of the former
president of Georgia,
Mikhail Saakashvili,
who is, of course, a foe of Putin.
And they say he's been poisoned by Putin.
They did DNA testing.
They said his arsenic levels were high.
They found a whole lot of other
things as well.
I just want to show everyone
a picture of Saakashvili
one year ago on the left.
On the right.
There he is.
Recently, he's in prison in Georgia
on abuse of power charges
which he says are false
and politically motivated.
But I want to share with you, Bill,
a letter that I got, a moving
note that I got from Saakashvili
after I spoke with his lawyer.
And I've known Mr.
Saakashvili for a long time.
You can see from the handwriting here.
And that's
part of what's hard to watch here.
He suffered physical repercussions
and it is hard to look at that.
And people can read it.
He writes,
I really regret
that he didn't see me in Kiev
as I had already gone on
my ill fated trip.
Bill,
do you have any hope
that Mikheil Saakashvili
will be freed and survive?
Well, I mean, what I what I see is
is something
truly horrific and heartbreaking
This is a politically motivated arrest
is being tortured in prison.
The images that you've shown
are deeply disturbing.
I've lived through a similar situation
with my lawyer, Sergei
Magnitsky, who started out healthy
and ended up being tortured
to death
in prison, denied medical care
and dying in prison.
And so for me, this is deja vu.
And when I saw those images of
Mikhail Saakashvili,
I spoke out.
And since then,
his team has been in touch with me.
I'm asking for my help,
asking for begging for my help
to do anything that I can do to help them
get him out of prison.
And it seems to me that he's being held,
I believe, at the behest of Russia.
Vladimir Putin has hated Saakashvili
since Saakashvili
stood up to Putin in 2008
when Russia invaded Georgia.
And Putin.
He never forgets.
He's a vindictive
little man who never forgets.
And what Georgia has to do right now
is release Saakashvili to the west
so he can be treated properly
and he doesn't die.
Because if he were to die in prison,
I believe that this would change
the West's view of Georgia.
For many generations